hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to one finger death
punch I have know the reason for playing
the southern that I really want to and I
have a lot of fun when I do so here we
go in case you didn't already know about
this game it's incredibly unbelievably
absolutely unbelievably fun and I might
get away from me I'm not ready for you
come on Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam oh man
you guys don't even know well I mean you
probably do I'm all off RISM hang on
there we go it's been a while oh come on
Peter crap it's been way too long I'm
better than oh there we go okay we got
him we got him down the ground and we
got it boom bang bang bang but oh so
good Oh
like I didn't even deserve it but I
killed him anyway because I felt like it
oh I didn't even do well but I still
feel like I'm amazing then again I am
pretty awesome hmm wait a minute what
does that mean retro film round I've
never played a retro film round form oh
it's all retro II I see there's really
nothing the Krauts what I know how to
play the game well apparently I don't
because I'm pretty terrible I can't even
tell ya
yeah bum bum bum bum bum buh buh buh buh
buh bah bow bail bail bail bail Oh
love you guys have had a chance to play
this game but it's absolutely phenomenal
in everywhere like I can't even explain
how it is unless you play for yourself
it is just ridiculously fun okay
oh I almost died okay it's about time
whoo okay I can that something to have
this really it
yes okay I got it I got it I got I got I
gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta got
it come on dead dead dead dead dead dead
dead very good
oh no no like the first time I ever
failed how could I fail I'm so good at
games
barely nine who are you her egg direct
you're right beating my face it too bad
I'm just not good enough at the game
apparently Oh super bonus what did I get
so bad at this game I'm good I swear I
must restore honor for my family
it's amazing the game actually becomes
harder towards the end of the game I
never would imagine it could have been
this way how could this happened to me
Oh oh come on you broke my camera had a
camber going you don't want to interrupt
Marga Blair's canvas
I'm so great or gold a medal I did it
when you accomplish this game when you
actually do it well it feels so good
thank you
okay one at a time huh what oh I see oh
I see oh oh you are my daggers are you
want to walk into my wall of dagger
death my douchey wall of dagger
destitution and death oh you made a
mistake coming here
perfect
oh so good it games are so good at games
okay smash round I'm imagining I need to
break things I think I played this one
before I'm pretty sure I did this one
whoa watch is my bar grows big like
smash things into you are you into
things right either way I don't really
judge BAM Oh what what about you baloney
oh you thing this magical sky god is
depositing all these things for me to
break sure I'm sorry forever I'm to
payroll you know you know after the
first time that I played this game I had
to go back and watch eat mana Netflix
just because like I really liked the
movie this cuz it's so badass
and everybody thing about it Oh some of
them out like the the Chinese kung-fu
movies god I love him you know the
Chinese was nothing that would be
anything else
victory speed up for after I win hmm non
chuckle oh oh oh you think you're gonna
win
the answer is apparently no oh hey hey
hey look at that back up back up back up
are you there we're back up hi hi still
away from a survivor right oh oh oh you
hurt my nose oh crap oh I'm surging with
power my control is broken I'm in us
this morning in this lag playing online
against actual people that's how good I
am
goddamnit Wow oh I didn't know I didn't
know who's gonna be like that
yeah hey made a mistake oh come on oh I
felt so good about that one - about how
you would get multi million points
probably by being better than me but
that's not impossible how could anyone
even how could anyone even be better
than excuse that mess
oh well that was easy
sounds like nothing oh all right good
for me
only 25 only 25 Oh miss me
am i miss me I mean I killed you dead oh
come on Oh one he kills me but I won't
fail cuz I'm amazing
oh I was taking my time haha [ __ ] y'all
thank you good night see you next time
it's so cool oh no I miss goddamnit I
was gonna get perfect you'll pay for
ruining my perfect streak
you'll pay for making me look bad I
didn't grab the weapon but now I did oh
damn it
uh uh I was gonna be perfect
I love the dumb cell banging in the
background everyone knows that in kung
fu times dub set was the perfect
fighting music career club I got the
club master I didn't finish the song
there but I finished passionately so
long as you finish with passion that's
all that matters in life okay so that's
enough one finger death punch for now I
have a ton of fun playing this every
single time I play this game it always
puts a giant smile on my face so I hope
you guys watching it as much as I love
playing it so thank you everybody so
much for watching check out the other
times I played this game in the
description below our annotations over
there
and check out the other awesome games
that I played as well and as always I
will see you in the next video
I miss another Prince so kingdoms gonna
crumble oh well
slice me no oh